[Music]
all right hey everybody welcome back 6
43 it is time for mondays with monica so
happy to be here with you this week we
are talking tanaji
all of you who love jazz you guys know
this guy multi platinum
grammy nominated saxophonist flowers he
can play more instruments than that just
so you know
he's worked with stevie wonder quincy
jones herbie hancock
prince toby keith babyface and tony
braxton
just to name a few we don't have time to
tell you who else he has worked with
but we are so happy to have him with us
and he is very familiar
with las vegas he has a new cd it's
called center of the heart naji thank
you so much for being here what a
pleasure how you doing
i'm doing well it's good to see you
monica i miss coming to vegas and
performing there though out of all those
things you said you know that's
that's one of the things i certainly
missed for sure very cool i know the
last time you were here you were up at
aliante but you've been around vegas to
a lot of the casinos right
uh well before aliante we've been to uh
gosh i forget some of them but yeah of
course i've been there with prince and
i played several uh sub a little bit uh
what's the one called i can't remember
now but anyway
several times you know as you know over
the years yeah yeah
one of my favorite you know vegas is one
of those places like gone because you
got the big marquis so you really make
me look like i'm a real star
[Laughter]
look we know you are really a star and
you know you have a big following here
in las vegas
before we get into your new music naji
again i mean
you're iconic but i know you've hung out
with some iconic folks as well
including the king family in honor of dr
king dave tell us that quick story
oh well i had the pleasure of meeting
them over the years several times i
actually met mrs king as well years ago
uh and also i had the pleasure at the
freedom center in atlanta
uh presenting an award a freedom award
to uh tony bennett
a great jazz vocalist uh i was one
designated to give him the award for his
contribution to civil
rights so i've known them over the years
always run into them
you know yeah as part of uh part of the
social events that
that i attend from here here and there
yeah we know they're fancy events you
don't have to hold back
hey let's get into fancy because
center of the heart that's your your new
release
not really new but we never got a chance
to really jam out on it because
everything was shut down and you didn't
get to tour with it right talk about
that
that's true yes actually when we were
about to start i was actually over in
the uk
uh doing promotional work for when the
pandemic hidden had to cut everything
short and come home
so uh since march of last year i've been
here
at home yeah so so tell me about this
collaboration because i know when you do
something
you don't just stick right there in your
studio by yourself
you bring on some of the big names and i
want to hear that print story too
oh okay well on this particular cd kenny
lattimore is one of my guests on there
uh
so i had the pleasure of having him um
and we we departed a little bit we did
one orchestral piece of alfie i think
you probably know that song by bert
bacarat
yeah you know so it's it was a great cd
to just have fun with
and uh i didn't write everything myself
this time i collaborated with quite a
few people babyfaces producer
yeah and many others you know so uh it
it
it's it's done well we did have a number
one smooth jazz song on face to face so
yeah you got something out of it so far
we just popped up pictures saw you with
patti labelle here but real quick
tell everybody this story about prince
najee because it blew me away but i mean
this is your world so it's not like a
big deal for you but it is for us
sure well you know i'll try to make it
quick but you know when i was leaving
the label i was with at the time emi
records
uh and i was touring with prince his
attorney uh the same attorney that got
him out of the warner brothers deal
was the attorney that uh took on the
case for me
to get out of my deal with capital
records capital emi
and uh at the end of the whole thing you
know i was prepared to
pay whatever fees were were due but
the attorney told me well you don't only
own anything you know you don't owe
anything and
so prince paid my legal oh quietly
he never said a thing to me about it he
never deducted anything out of
money he would pay me i mean that's just
the kind of guy he was he was always
very very one of the most generous
people i ever met in my life
that is an awesome story hey i'm just
about out of time i want you
to tell everybody where they can get
center of the heart and you're going to
play us out
uh into our next segment too tell us
where we can get your music
well you can get it amazon you know you
can amazon of course
itunes of course you can download
go right ahead
[Music]
all right ladies and gentlemen yes
iconic
in the world of jazz music all together
we appreciate you nazi
take care and stop by anytime okay good
to see you monica
all right folks and don't forget catch
me tonight on the mlj show facebook live
from 7 p.m on we'll just entertain you
and if you
missed the interview we'll do the replay
for you as well